innovation master Series is the only
class that I know of where it's all
senior professors people who have been
teaching design at Stanford for 20 or 30
years who come together and give their
best 90 minutes of teaching content
exercises and takeaways so you really
are learning from you know the best of
the best here at Stanford and people who
have been studying innovation for a long
long time
people who are in a situation where they
have to make those decisions there are
general managers of a group that is
really struggling to come up with new
ideas people who want to work on how to
there may be they may feel they have
innovative organizations but their teams
don't work as effectively together as
they might certainly people who are
struggling to understand well I spend a
lot of money on innovation but I don't
really know what I get for it
the way you get data is your prototype
so we're a prototype based design
methodology and Design Thinking relies
on that so we have as a consequence of
that some of the best prototyping labs
in the world here you'll have an
opportunity to see what we call the
product realization lab where we build
not only products but experiences and
services the biomimetics robot lab where
we've built robots that fly and land
like birds or can climb up the sides of
buildings like a gecko a Center for
Automotive Research at Stanford are what
we call our cars lab where the
autonomous vehicles that won the DARPA
challenge that have done the Pikes Peak
Race these are cars that drive
themselves will be there the solar car
will be there
I would hope to see you come to campus I
guarantee of the three days will be you
know full of information full of
activities and you'll meet some of the
most interesting participants and
instructors and any conference you've
ever been to
you